hey guys it's Justine I'm here with RO
no today I thought we would do a row
reacts Wow
new iPhone just came out so it's now the
iPhone 11 Pro max there's an iPhone 11
Pro well just an iPhone 11 which comes
in five colors oh there's a lot to
choose from
wait okay there's a new phone there's
three of them they come bazillion colors
I don't have any of these so row I told
me that she broke her phone and you had
to go buy another one and it's like
right before this phone came out I know
it was just really really bad time I
have dropped my phone a million times
and every time it drops I'm like this is
the time it break and then I dropped it
again it broke my screen was flashing
green oh my goodness
green it was so weird I've never seen a
phone do this before and it was a couple
weeks before the new phone came out so
it's just bad timing so I just ended up
getting a 10 again I mean honestly the
10 is still a really great phone
actually you have the 10s I think do I I
think you should have the tennis yes
don't judge me for this case I'm not
that's okay it's I ordered another case
it's in the mail it's really sleek it's
like black with a little bit of white
marble and my pop socket ready for this
my new one is black and the top is black
crystals and it's svorski crystals
that's cool it is fancy eye with her
fancy pop socket but this is the one I
have right now it's just a cake with
sprinkles this is the 10s this is a 10
yeah so if you were to get another phone
I think this example I don't like the
big ones because they're too big in my
hands we've got some options for you so
this is the 11pro and this is the same
size as this one is the same size
new color midnight green oh my god this
looks like the little grills and those
little pictures I've been seeing online
just eat mini little soft spots on top
of them and that's what it looks like it
looks like a little stove it does really
look like a stone there's three cameras
which there's my back the flash oh and
so there's a wide and ultra wide and
telephoto so there's three but why would
you need a wide and ultra you do you
definitely want a slim I want to look
slim why doesn't make you why doesn't
make you wide there's also this one so
this is the iPhone 11 this one has two
cameras oh my gosh it's like this
beautiful lavender I've never seen this
before because it just came out
they never have this color didn't or
this is new so there's a lavender and
they have a really new mint green a
yellow or red and then a silver and then
a black and this one comes in silver the
midnight green and a gold midnight
Christmas grey I can't wait to show you
this whoa this only has to camp Zeeland
and this is view of the pro so these are
the pro versions so this one rolled up a
story has three cameras it has a faster
processor and it has an OLED Retina
screen whereas this one just has an LCD
screen so the quality isn't as good as
this it's still an incredibly fast phone
and it has the new wide angle on there I
gotta show you the camera oh if that's
the main thing about this let me see
this wide and Noble that you're talking
about here this is the regular okay and
this is the zoom so that's the telephoto
so you can zoom in and here's the wide
Wow
yeah dude dude no one's a picture of you
okay ready oh my gosh like I can see all
of Kenya well are you sure
okay I'm stuck in here we're gonna need
you to picture me okay Mike is he or you
guys smile I got Mike in here yeah
because it's so wide go hit the middle
one et tu photo
so if you have to use like 100
it's so cute cookies on the ground you
can see little cookie - yeah because
it's a wide angle Wow
so these would be really good for like
room photos like hey let's see picture
yeah because you can see like because
you can see the room okay that one's
okay but look at my feet you know it
does distort it like a little bit but I
think what's the best part about the
ultraviolet is for like landscape photos
or if you're trying to get in like a
whole table of people like didn't okay
then you fit in there okay that's really
cool and this is cool so and they'll pay
up front they see okay like this so when
you automatically turn this okay it will
automatically you use the more room
because it'll think there's more people
in the frame hey she turned it and it
zoomed back so it gave us more space
pretty cool okay this is amazing because
as someone who has a very short farm and
when I'm trying to take selfies with
somebody there's not a lot of space
between my hand and the lens like and I
have the short arm and I'm always like
can someone else taking it cuz my arms
are so short yes but actually that more
space to work with wait which phones can
do that the new ones they don't get all
of them yeah yeah so this one does it as
well the difference between us is it
doesn't have the telephoto lens but it
also has the ultra wide also has a
front-facing 4k camera now so before it
was only 1080 they also have
front-facing slow-mo so now okay tell me
what you think what they're calling them
slow fees slow fees what do you mean
okay show me okay
absolutely let's take a slow fee okay
oh no I'm gonna basically when I hit the
button just kind of like go like mad or
something yeah if you will look already
okay
all right let's see our slow fee
I don't even know what we've started yet
me arse loafing we slow feed wow you're
just better you were moving more do we
can I do have a long time I want one
more slow fee me I do know how to do it
all day okay are you ready move my hair
okay I'm so ready to go that's a good
this is great yes they have some new
editing features so you can actually
have filters on to your video so this is
is certein update so you'll actually
have this update as well they're gonna
have filters yes thank goodness because
sometimes I'm taking videos and I don't
have the best lighting mmm it's just
dark and you can't see how cute my dogs
are you can't see how cute so I use a
filter to make it brighter yes you can
adjust you can do an auto you can adjust
exposure so this is only get lighter
yeah so this is all built into iOS 13 I
mean it's basically like anything that
used to be able to do you're like on the
photos you can now do in the video and
then you can save it this is so cool so
you love it up I always yes so just all
you have to do is update your phone
update from okay that's not quite update
update now update now and obviously this
will work on you know the older versions
when you have iOS 13 but it's much
faster using the a 13 Bionic chip hello
I just LOF Ian this is so cool oh look
yeah that was good oh my gosh I have
here for this low fee and I I'm really
excited about it you know what I really
want to try it on when this update
happens on my phone yeah I want to fill
my dog's cuz they do the funniest like
when they like lick their little mouths
or their tongues they like so you can do
slow-mo but you wouldn't be able to do
it on the front-facing camera cuz that's
new on the iPhone pros - 11 so that's an
iPhone 11 thing but yeah you can still
just logo on yours okay deal and it
would be better anyway because you're
gonna be foot if I type my phone again
then I can get a new one and then I can
slow fee all I want I mean you could say
Mike why don't you use this iPhone and
what's it mighty enough here's a gift
for you which please like think holding
his Android
and he's like never unboxed his f10 it
was if yeah after it came out but it's
okay because we still fit it it was one
of his first unboxing videos it was
pretty great yeah you showed him the
ropes how to unbox something he got he
did good he did it book did a computer
it's very bright and I was really proud
of him cuz he did that after I really
love this color now what do they call
this lavender or just like they called
it purple but it's really wonderful okay
here's the new cupcake and there's this
mint green green is really really really
pretty yellows nice from the lavender
love it I love the red to the color that
I want this pink if they haven't got a
beautiful pink is so great a bright pink
yeah I mean basically the main
difference is obviously it's faster and
I mean you have the new the new lenses
with ultra wide it's gonna be really
cool to look at I got a question
official question from somebody who's
not very good with technology which
camera do you look at I would say you
just look in the middle because we like
right in the middle right in the middle
of all that's Universal you have a
friend taking a picture look at all
these there's all these going on I'm
like where do I love just look somewhere
in this general yeah you'll be good I'll
be looking like I'm looking at
everything yeah I've you know on the
front facing though I mean I'm here so
you just have to look like kind of up at
the top like right by the speaker just
look at this beaker you think okay I'm
gonna look at this piece okay see okay
and I'm gonna smile at the speaker does
that look like I'm looking at the cop
yes look at that oh my gosh it does I
know okay we're good
I love this I'm so fascinated by new
technology even though I don't stay on
top of it the only way I know what's
going on is when Justine comes over and
she shows me all of the cool stuff on my
phone and new phones yeah the only
reason I even know how to record my own
screen or about those cute little emoji
MIMO jamming out of G's the only reason
I even knew those were on my phone it's
cuz of Justine cuz I just used my phone
to call people and like send emails and
do my social media stuff other than that
I had no idea all the cool things that
my phone could do we made
Thank You emoji videos about this point
on Iowa 13 beta it was so much fun
everyone loved it in shock wait is this
the small one this is the big one yeah
this is the 11 this is the 11 Pro and
this is the pro max is the max the
biggest this is the big guy so it's
basically the same size as the previous
one used to have a big one but I
actually switched to do a smaller one
because my hands are small I have little
little nugget hands well thanks for
checking out the new iPhone with me I'm
gonna have to bring over some more tech
for you guys
what tech should I bring over next to
show oh my gosh anything please please
comment down below tell Justine what to
bring over I want to see everything oh
my god talk one what tech stuff do you
got I don't know got any robots I might
say drones I've got all of the things
can you teach me how to fly a drone yes
I will or is it too expensive it's too
fancy it would be worth it hi drew oh my
gosh what if I crash it though oh maybe
that's a little bit yeah a real size
drone what about something on the ground
I have a little robot that you can drive
around it's like a ground drone better
because I'm gonna get I'm gonna fly one
into the tree or something cool guys
thank you so much for watching bro
thanks so much for checking out the
iPhones it's really great you guys want
to see some more iPhone videos or check
out some of ROS videos we have done so
many videos together so I'll put a
playlist and hope that you guys enjoy
checking them out we'll see you soon
[Music]